vu de la guerre on vous parle
régulièrement de ses combattants
étrangers qui rejoignent soit les rangs
des Russes ou soit des Ukrainiens cette
fois on passe à un cran au-dessus
bonjour wassimnas vous nous parlez d'un
commandant tchétchène un vétéran de la
guerre de Tchétchénie et de Siri qui a
rejoint l'Ukraine et l'armée de Kiev à
darkmouth d'abord comment est-ce qu'il a
fait pour rejoindre l'Ukraine ben c'est
le grand mystère on sait pas comment il
a fait pour quitter la série et
rejoindre l'Ukraine on sait juste qu'il
a été arrêté en Turquie ces derniers
mois pour l'histoire d'extension de
fonds dont il a été blanchi puis on sait
pas comment il a réussi à quitter la
Turquie pour rejoindre l'Ukraine est-ce
que quelqu'un lui a facilité la tâche on
sait par contre qu'il a sa famille en
Pologne est-ce que c'était un vol direct
Turquie
Ukraine où est-ce qu'il est passé par la
Pologne avec des papiers des vrais
papiers des faux papiers on ne sait pas
mais le fait est que là on voit à
l'image son arrivée dans la ville de de
crivoï où il est accueilli par une
délégation des tchétchen de de
l'opposition donc avant de rejoindre les
combats à Mahmoud donc ce sont des
images qui date de quelques jours le
voilà donc Abdelhakim chichini de son
vrai nom Rouston azayev donc c'est un
commandant militaire il faut le dire
avec beaucoup de compétences militaires
vétérans de la bataille de Grozny 2e et
vétéran de la guerre en Syrie et là on
le voit donc dans les guerres de rue les
guerres urbaines le voilà là qui fait
descendre les combattants dans les caves
donc après pour des tunnels pour
ressortir de l'autre côté et combattre
la messe donc c'est un combattant qui se
bat contre la mer russe depuis le milieu
des années 2000 depuis la Tchétchénie
bataille de groseilles puis série dès
2015 il était à la tête d'un groupe qui
s'appelle Agena de El kafcase qui avait
élu domicile dans le nord de l'attaquer
et qui a participé à la bataille d'edlib
là on le voit à edelipeville après la
prise de la ville par les rebelles et
les djihadistes il y avait les deux hein
il faut il faut le dire et là on voit
avec le chef du gouvernement en exil
tchétchène à son arrivée en Ukraine fin
fin 2022 donc il a été accueilli ça il
faut le dire par Ahmed Zakaiev qui a
fait déjà un appel à tous les
combattants de cette chaîne de rejoindre
l'Ukraine dès 2014 et les combats au
Dombasle il est pas allé tout seul il
est avec d'autres combattants mais dans
ce cadre très spécifique on sait combien
de soldats il a sous son aile puisque
c'est pas un simple combattant vous le
disait c'est un commandant quelques
dizaines on dit long accompagné depuis
la série mais sa valeur ajoutée c'est
comme vous le dites c'est un commandant
qui a l'expérience des combats face aux
Russes depuis des années et surtout la
guerre urbaine d'où sa présence au front
à barcode donc c'est pas de la
figuration c'est un vrai commandant
militaire qui a un vrai CV on va dire
derrière lui pourquoi il a quitté la
série maintenant et
quel implications cela donne à cette
arrivée en Ukraine il a quitté la série
parce qu'on est dans une conjoncture
depuis quelques années maintenant ou le
groupe dominant à de libre donc HTS
essaient de se débarrasser des
combattants étrangers qui ont rejoint la
série pour asseoir son autorité mais
aussi pour contenter le côté turc qui
veut clore ce dossier donc HTS on l'a
dit ici avec vous à plusieurs reprises à
clos plusieurs dossiers dont le dossier
des otages donc un dossier d'otages dans
lequel le groupe de Abdelhakim était
impliqué à un moment avec l'équipe
napping d'un travailleur de MG
britannique qui a été libéré après et
deux personnes du groupe ont été détenus
par HTS donc les prisons de HTS sont
pleines de combattants étrangers donc
des Français s'il faut s'il faut le
rappeler parce qu'il leur donne un
ultimatum ça veut dire vous rentrez en
prison vous restez dans les rangs où
vous quittez vous quittez donc via la
Turquie et lui comme un autre commandant
de tchétchène qui sont une des têtes
d'affiches donc des commandants qui ont
un vrai CV un vrai pedigree et des
hommes HTS les oblige à quitter
aujourd'hui la série sinon c'est la
prison donc ces deux dans cette
conjoncture là qu'il a quitté la série
après encore une fois est-ce que le
départ depuis la Turquie a été facilité
ça on le sait pas l'impact sur le
terrain on y croit en Ukraine on verra
ce n'est qu'un homme finalement avec
quelques combattants on sait aussi qu'il
n'a jamais appartenu à un groupe
djihadiste
il a même combattu l’état islamique à 1
à un certain un certain moment donc lui
et ses hommes vont être très suivis
parce qu'ils sont dans le cadre de des
forces ukrainiennes tchétchène anti
antirius présente en Ukraine sachant que
les services Ukrainiens avant la guerre
de février ont collaboré même avec les
Russes pour expulser des tchétchène qui
était connu pour l'appartenance à l'état
islamique donc c'est quelque chose à
suivre de très près et comme vous l'avez
très bien rappelé au début des
combattants étrangers viennent des deux
côtés aujourd'hui si on ne peut pas dire
que les tchétchen de kadyrophares sont
étrangers parce qu'ils appartiennent à
la Fédération de Russie on sait que dans
les rangs de Wagner par exemple il y a
aussi des combattants de pays africains
maintenant qui se battent en Ukraine et
du côté ukrainien il y a des tchétchen
il y a des Géorgiens il y a des Tatars
de Crimée mais qui sont
Ukrainiens finalement donc voilà plus la
guerre dure plus on va voir des
combattants arrivés et plus ça sera
difficile aux autorités respectives des
deux côtés de tenir et de surveiller ce
qui se passe merci pour ces révélations
et